I was watching a tick tock of an old
white guy giving Financial advice was
getting torn apart by all these
Tick-Tock commenters they're like who is
this guy fake Guru blah blah blah the
man was Ray Dahlia you don't know who he
is he's worth over 30 billion dollars
and when I saw that I thought to myself
if Ray Dalia is getting questioned on
his authenticity by people who don't
know him who am I to believe that I'm
somehow going to be immune to people who
comment ignorantly and to be fair it's
reasonable that they have that
assumption because most people are full
of and so if you know that you're
not full of that's the only opinion
that really matters